i'm nicola beven and uh as the anita had
always commented with the title of the
webinar
um so in today's webinar we're going to
cover how real-time
lifestyle analysis of antibody
internalization
can provide additional biological
insight and enhance productivity
with the use of the inclusite fab floor
ph reagent to provide a turnkey approach
to antibody labeling
and then we will share some examples of
how this assay can be used for
characterization
of early stage test antibodies in a
biologics discovery paradigm
so why are we interested in studying
antibody internalization
in the year of 2016 the global cells for
therapeutic antibodies was in excess of
90 billion dollars
and these therapeutic antibodies have
been used across a range of disease
areas including anti-cancer
anti-inflammatory and anti-viral agents
now the extent and the rate of the
internalization into cells
governs the efficacy and the safety and
the pharmacodynamic profile of these
reagents
and this is through both specific
target-mediated or non-specific
mechanisms like pinocytosis and as with
any small drug molecule
small modifications to the antibody can
affect the duration of action
and obviously some of these important
therapeutic agents are antibody drug
conjugates where we're looking at the
delivery of a drug payload to cells
so in there are currently many um
assays to look at antibody
internalization
and current methods for quantification
of internalization
are current currently limited and
they're mainly microscopy or flow
cytometry based
they're often time consuming and not
amenable to testing large numbers of
samples
and there's a requirement for a large
quantity of the antibody
to allow the direct fluorescent labeling
and is often restricted to endpoint
assays with multiple experiments
required for a temporal profile
and because of this these assays are
often limited to later key
stage antibodies so why are we
interested in using
live cell analysis um so lifestyle
analysis systems
should combine all of these features on
the slide here so an automated real-time
analysis
to allow a full kinetic profile be image
based to allow you to look at cell
interactions and morphologies
but also flexible enough to fit into
existing workflows
with the use of multiple different
optics readouts
and the ability to look at various
different cells and vessels
and often allowing the multiplexing with
different assay readouts
for the instance of the inkyocite it
sits within the incubator
so there's a full environmental control
there to allow your cells to be
happy in their normal environment and
most importantly for the reagents
they need to be non-perturbing over
these longer term studies
and be validated for use in lifestyle
protocols
so if we look at the application
principle in the diagram here
what we're introducing is the incucite
fab floor reagent which is actually
a fragment of antibody or a fab
which has been pre-conjugated to a ph
sensitive probe
this then binds to the fc region of
a test antibody and labels the antibody
with the probe
we can then add the label test antibody
to our cells of interest
and on interaction with the targets the
antibody and the target will be
internalized into the cell
and once it enters the endosomal and
lysosomal pathway
you can see that the lysosomes get
increasingly acidic in nature
and it's this change in ph which causes
the
the change in fluorescence to cause the
red fl
the probe to fluoresce and if we look at
the characteristics of the
ph characteristics of the probe we can
see that at lower at higher
is a ph 7 there's a very low level of
fluorescence that's seen
and that rapidly increases as the ph of
the
environment becomes more acidic and this
gives us a nice rapid readout with our
with our die of interest
so if we now look to see what this looks
like on the inky site
here we can see a movie in bt 474 cells
which are a breast cancer cell line
and these are her2 positive and they
have been treated with a septum which is
conjugated to the fab floor reagents
and you can see even after six hours
there's a very bright
red signal within our cells and if we
look at the red only image
we can see this is very cytoplasmic in
nature and very punctate
which you would expect if it was
entering the lysosomal pathway
if we now look at the workflow that's
involved you can see it
is a very simple workflow to use this
application
the first step is to seed your cells
into a plate and allow those to adhere
to the plastic
in another vessel and this can be a 96
well plate
we then mix the test antibody in
combination
with the fabflory agent and this is in a
one to three molar ratio
so of test antibodies a fab floor
and this can be performed in complete
media so in the presence of serum
the reaction takes about 15 minutes and
then once the antibody has been labeled
this can be added to your cell plate
and then that is immediately placed in
the inky site where we can begin to
collect images of our
internalization signal now by keeping
the reagents
and the plate and all the liquids at 37
degrees
we can ensure that we can capture a very
early signal without
with by lowering the risk of
condensation in our plate
and in some cells this response is very
rapid
so i think you can agree that the the
layout here
enables a very fast and simple labeling
method for
test antibodies there is no wash that's
required to remove the excess fab floor
reagent
and it's suitable for small quantities
of antibodies and large numbers of
antibodies
and in combination with the inc the
inky site software and incusi analysis
system
this gives us a fully integrated
solution for the application
if we now look in more detail at what is
happening within our cells
in these images here these are hd 1080
cells that have been treated with cd71
which is an antibody to the transferrin
receptor
and this has been labeled with the fab
flurry agent
and after six hours the image on the
left hand side
you can see there's a very clear red
fluorescent signal within the cytoplasm
of these cells the image on the right
hand side is of
an igg isotype control that has been
labeled in a similar manner
and you can see there is no red
fluorescence present
and if we now do a quantification of
those images you can see there's a very
fast rapid increase in the red object
area in the well
which is not seen in the isotype or the
media control wells
and this shows it's a very specific
cytoplasmic localization and specific
for the target antibody
and we can also say there's a nice rapid
time dependent increase in the signal
now from the image you can see that
obviously the number of cells is very
dependent on the
red area that we can see within the well
so we went on to validate that
um the how the signal size was dependent
on cell number
so in this scenario here we've put an
increasing number of hd 1080s in our
well
we've then treated them again with our
cd71 that's labeled for fab floor
and as you can see with the graph in the
middle here as the number of cells is
increased in the well
there is a large increase in the red
object area within the well
and this is in line with the number of
cells that have been added
if we now use the red object area and
actually normalize this for the phase
area
as a surrogate for the identity of cells
in the well
we end up with the data on the right
hand side here which shows that although
the signal size is dependent on cell
number
the actual rate of internalization of
the antibody in producing the signal
is cell number independent
and this is quite a nice example from
this data to show
that there is a signal size number is
dependent but actually the rate is
independent
we also want to go on to show that the
response that we're looking at is a
specific response
so in this scenario here we've taken
gerkats which are a t
cell-like cell line and rarjes which
were a b-cell-like cell line
and tested them with a range of cd
surface marker antibodies
that have been labeled with the fab
flurry agent
and in both instances here you can see
both cell lines gave a nice response to
cd 71
which is a very ubiquitously expressed
receptor i mean that's the green line
here
and then you can see that both cell
lines also give us a nice response to
cd45
which is a general lymphocyte marker but
only the t
cells will give us response to the cd3
and
only the b cells give us a nice clear
response with the cd20 marker
and we can we can then produce a nice
expression profile for these
for these cell lines now you'll also
note
that those particular cell lines um
although they have the same have a
response to cd71
the rajis appear to give a faster and a
larger
response than the jerk hats and we feel
that this may be dependent on the level
of receptor expression or the ability of
those cell lines to actually internalize
the marker
but the data set here gives us the
expected cd surface marker expression
profile
and also demonstrates that the signal we
see here although specific
it does give us a generic utility for
labeling multiple antibodies
and the last piece of validation data
here is showing that the
the antibody internalization signal we
see is actually within the lysosome
compartment of the cell
so in the set up here we have got hd
1080 cells again that have been treated
with cd71
and the top image on the right hand side
here shows the nice red
antibody internalization signal we've
then added
lysosensor which is a lysosomal marker
which gives us a green signal and this
is shown in the bottom left hand corner
then using the inkyocite software we can
look at the coincidence of the two
red mar the two coincident of the two
marker
within the cell and this is shown in
that yellow
marking there and if we look at the
quantification of the images
we can see that about 74 of the red
area in these cells is co-localized with
the green
area so it supports that the presence of
the internalized fat fluid reagent
is within the lysosomal compartments
we're now going to change track a little
bit and consider
how a therapeutic antibody is actually
selected and optimized within a drug
discovery setting
so in most instances the first stage
is to raise your antibody and this is
normally done as multiple hybridomas and
here we're normally looking in the range
of a thousand antibodies
normally producing low quantities and
within a mouse a rabbit
or a rat and the first step then is to
check for binding or engagement of the
antibody with the target
and this is obviously often done with
binding
and we're looking at binding
characteristics normally of around 500
to 1000 antibodies
the next step is to test these for
functional affinity ranking
and this is where the first early
cellular testing is normally carried out
and this is probably the first stage in
this pathway
where the real-time antibody
internalization assay could offer
um be enabling so at this stage we would
be looking at single concentration
screening of probably hundreds of
antibodies
and because we can label those in the
serum containing media we can use the
non-purified
hybridoma samples to allow direct
comparison of these samples
the next stage is often to take those
antibodies of interest
scale them up and then do further
functional evaluation on them
and again the application we're talking
about here
would allow you to look at full
concentration range profiling of those
reagents and possibly to do a rate
comparison of them
the next stage is often to take those
key
antibodies of interest and then humanize
them
ready for a therapeutic application and
again
the inky site can offer the full
concentration range profiling
mechanistic studies and also the
possibility to multiplex with this
additional readout
be that cell health or other readouts
so what does this actually look like so
to actually show this
um we purchased in a range of
commercially available cd71 antibodies
and tested those in a head-to-head
screening scenario
and what we're looking at here on the
left hand side are the plate views taken
from the inky site software
and this shows that these antibodies
tested in triplica as a full
concentration response curve
you can see the full temporal response
for those antibodies and we can clearly
see
that antibody 1a was a little bit more
potent than antibody
two which was more potent than antibody
three
and then we have controls in column ten
eleven and twelve
with a nice clear positive response in
column eleven
um reassuringly antibody 1a and 1b were
the same clone but purchased from
alternative suppliers and these give
very similar responses
the image in the middle here is a deep
view which can be taken from the incusi
s3 software and this is shown for a
single time point
and what you can see here is the red
fluorescent signal in the plate
and you can clearly see there's a clear
positive response in column 11
and you can see an increasing effect
with our compounds as we go
up the plate showing the nice response
that we're looking at
so this is showing you that the label
labeling protocol is suitable for
multiple test antibodies
and it will enable that direct
head-to-head screening
it's 96 well plate compatible for both
the labeling
and obviously the cell readout it's
suitable for samples that contain serums
so suitable for those early hybridoma
samples
and it's suitable for small quantities
of sample
and the plate view within the inkysite
software allows a very clear
quick visualization of the response
but obviously we can do a full
characterization of the response here
and this is the quantification data from
those plates
so in the bar graph here i'm actually
showing only the data from the 12
hour time point and you can the first
couple of bars on the graph here are the
positive and negative control wells
and you can see there's a clear positive
response and if you calculate the z
prime values for this data
we're looking at z primes of 0.75 and
0.87
which is indicative of a very high
quality assay
we can now see the full concentration
response curves for the various
antibodies that we tested
and in this particular setting antibody
1a and 1b
look very similar antibody 2 is a little
bit less potent
and antibody 3 4 and 5 are only giving
us responses at the highest
concentrations
so as i said before the data here is
only displayed as a
single time point but the full temporal
response was also collected
along with the phase confluency of which
we can then use to assess if there are
any effects of the test articles on cell
health or proliferation
and the asset position and the workflow
would enable the comparison of a hundred
hundreds of antibodies
but if you required further throughput
with z primes of
this quality it would be amenable to be
miniaturized into a three eighth l
four well format so the next stage would
be to look at your
antibodies of interest in further detail
so the data shown here
is looking at a her2 response again
and again we're in our bt474 cells and
again
we're looking at herceptin that's been
labeled with the fab floor reagent
so the graph on the left hand side shows
increasing concentrations of herceptin
on ourselves
and we can see a nice clear increase in
that internalization response over the
48-hour time point
if we now take the area under the curve
and do an analysis
we can then plot a full concentration
response curve
which allows us to calculate the
midpoint or the ec
50 for this data and with anything
within incusite this is fully backed up
with the images
so if we look at the images on the right
hand side here
we can see a nice clear red signal
within our bt474 cells
and a very very weak non-specific igg
isotype control response
so we can see there's a very rapid
concentration dependent increase
in our specific signal over time
the next set of data is with an
alternative cell line and in this case
we're looking in rarji cells so a
non-adherent cell type
and this time we're looking at an
anti-cd20 antibody
rituxan which again has been labeled
with our fab floor
reagent and just with the herceptin data
you can see a nice concentrated related
response
with this reagent on our cells and again
we can assess the midpoint or the ec 50
value for this data
and the images clearly show a nice
specific red signal
for the rituxan on these cells
so in conclusion i i hope you feel that
the data that we've presented today
shows that the incucite fabflor red
reagent is suitable for a quick and easy
generic labeling of test antibodies
it can be used with non-purified
antibodies in serum containing media
and there's a very low background signal
due to the use of the ph sensitive probe
it's a fully integrated assay solution
with simple workflow and automated
analysis
it's image based with real-time assay
providing a full kinetic profile and
morphological insight
and it enables the comparison of test
antibodies early in that discovery
pathway
it also has the ability to be multiplex
with additional readouts if required
so real-time life cell analysis coupled
with the incucite fabful red
reagent enables direct cell-based
antibody internalization measurement
to provide additional biological insight
and enhanced productivity
for the evaluation of therapeutic
antibodies
so thank you very much for your time if
you require any further information
please visit the website there's a full
application note on there and there's
more information and the table at the
bottom here just shows the particular
reagents that are available
for this application